um
first thing is apologies and there are
none
zoom attendees we have lindsey mckenzie
and first up we have a public forum
with mr vic west talking about audio
crossing signals welcome back
we can shift
here representing blind citizens
association
and we're deeply concerned about the
the lack of maintenance around the
audible crossing signals
and the length of time they've actually
taken to
be repaired um now i'll just run through
um on the early march
i rang the 032 you know triple 1 triple
seven and request for service
on the crossing signals on the
corner of leet and kelvin street
in spain and
corner of space street this is on the
northwest corner
and also dawn street also on the door on
the
northwest corner those three i reported
those in early march
so anyway i became aware
of another one which was close to the
blind foundation near the corner of
garda street and
on the north west corner again so
and this was another member told me this
was not working but she
was not unable unable to get across
there to get the bus
and so i was i believe i told her to
contact the council
and request service but i added this on
the
middle of march i rang through and told
them
that the gala street one was not so
there was those four
and about a week later i checked up and
only that one on the space street
had been repaired so that's about the
22nd of march something around about
that time i'm pretty sure it was
and but i note that that one there
had been damaged but anyway
going back um
i then went back about a week later and
found that the
lead street one was been repaired that
had already been done
that store left the gala street and the
don street one
now i went along there
um two or three times
the first time i went along to the
corner of don street
and stood on the corner by the building
there and i could barely hear it
barely i could hear the one on the don
street kelvin street crossing
working okay but
i had to walk forward and find them met
and then locate where the um
signal box on the don street was and
then then i could hear
just faintly here the signal coming from
that
so then i went up and pushed the button
and it actually went and so
um and so
that was i said well as far as i know
that one is
still hasn't been fixed
but i been telling people that they
should give that a wide birth because
of the amount of work that's been
carried off in don street and
probably not really um you need to
attend to that one i guess
for a while anyway um but getting back
to the gala street one i was a bit
concerned about that because there are
some members who use that
and so it was on the 7th of april was my
last call and i said that that hadn't
been
been repaired so there was some point
after the
april the 7th that that one was fixed so
i can report that that one has
been repaired okay
now um going back to the
i'll also mr chairman i want to
voice our other concern about the
dual pedestrian crossing signal
the one side on the corner of saint
andrew street
in queens drive saint andrews street and
gala street
now i just um
as you know it's when you approach it
and push the button and
the voice message comes up press the
button
if you need the longer crossing push it
until the red light appears
and it beeps
i done that but of course i can't see
the red light
and i can't hear no signal this is on
the corner
north corner of san andreas street the
message is a little bit scratchy
but not too bad but when i went to the
south side
i found that the
sounds there for that one was
was hardly was very noisy i could i
couldn't understand it
then i turned over to the queen's drive
side one
that was a bit scratchy too but it was
audible enough but still again
nice push the button in for the longer
service
and still no beep
went across to the other side of queen's
drive
there is no voice message there
and went down to the gala street
crossing
no voice message there either
so i'm not too sure what's happened
there whether that's been removed or
it's just not working i don't know
now in respect to this your pedestrian
crossing signal
our association felt it was a great
thing because
the late uh carol swale and myself we
showcased this to the
country through a length with ct
on the national pro on the national tv
and we thought was a wonderful thing and
it's not a it's a crossing for
not only people with disabilities but
people
for ever everyone who has problems uh
with
say young children woman with prams or
young children crossing
and they want the longer crossing and
it's great
so we supported that on the and we took
it to conference
in national conference and they adopted
as part of their policy
so i i just think i would like to see
that
we restored to back to its original
um state and um
remind people that you know it's it's up
and going and keep
keep reminding them to
that this is you know the crossing that
we
really believe in um
i um i really haven't got much more to
say
on mata but um
yeah so i that's about it mr chairman i
just hope that
we can get some action in restoring that
thing because i think it's it's
important
and you know because of the people come
down here and they probably
um and that's i understand they've
actually got it going up into meru but i
don't know how well it's working up
there i guess
but you know it's something that we
should be proud of here
um thank you thank you vic for that what
i'm going to do now
is um russell uh would you like to
to speak to this because obviously we've
got some questions coming but i think
it's probably best if
if you were able to like address some of
the some of the initial concerns
and then then i'll open it up to
questions
just about the the actual functions of
these
these particular so it's more about
about the functionality of these um
thanks mr chuman and
good afternoon um i will definitely
follow up with their contractor our
contractors
um inspect the audible signals
um on a reasonably regular basis and i
know the last one was done in march but
i'll follow up
to that today and we'll obviously be
doing those and liaise back to vic
in terms of the the crossing it's an
industry that was actually undertaken
um as a trial it's not been adopted
nationally and
and i understand um and one of the
issues that we
will have over a longer time is that
it's got a whole lot of extra components
and
whilst i understand vic's desire for it
to be there we've
tried to keep it going we just need to
keep make sure those components which
are a little bit more
i guess vulnerable to vandalism and
moisture egress just to make sure they
are able to operate and i haven't been
there in the last for a little while to
check but i'll get the team to do so
now thanks for that russell so that's
just answered those initial questions
um the what i'm going to do now is
is open up questions just for vic only
russell was just purely to give us a bit
of a brief on how that all works as far
as maintenance goes
so any questions for vic
councillors no
all good okay vic thank you very much
and uh
we will have um some sort of report come
back
to council uh with your concerns
okay now thank you very much for the
opportunity thank you
right thank you
right that moves on to a major
late item that we haven't have put to us
um this is in relationship
to change in delegations in relation to
property sale of lower s street
uh it's going to be in public excluded
the reason it's a major late item is the
late receipt
of the material needed for this matter
so and the reason why it is going into
public excluded
is so that matter can be progressed in a
timely manner
to get put forward to council
don't move
thank you um i'll put that emotionalist
in favor
hi against that is carrick
right we'll move on to
minutes of the infrastructure services
mini meeting
held on the 1st of june what i'm going
to ask for is
confirmation of the minute minutes and
also reminding that
we have a recommendation that will go
through to an extraordinary council
meeting
on the 10th of august
so can i have someone move that
move that thank you councillor sopo
seconded councillor munson will put that
motion on those four
hi against it's carried next we have the
minutes of the extraordinary meeting of
the infrastructure services committee
held
27 july 2021
can i have someone confirm those minutes
please thank you
alex and thank you graeme
i put the motion all those in favor hi
again that is carried now we have an
verbal update from erin on
three water water reform thank you chair
the purpose of this verbal update
is just to initiate some discussion and
ensure that we are all on the same page
as a council around
where we are currently at on the three
waters reform
agenda that is currently underway
as we're all aware the new zealand
government initiated a range of three
waters reforms
uh which are currently still underway
now in 2021
just as history over the past two
decades there's been
a large number of government and private
sector reports
that have talked to a wide range of
issues
um in the three waters space throughout
new zealand
the current reforms that are in front of
us at the moment were triggered by the
havelock north
incident in 2016 where contaminated
groundwater
entered the water network and resulted
in 5 000 people becoming
unwell and for consequential deaths
a subsequent central government inquiry
observed that new zealand had fallen
quite a ways behind
best practice in the delivery of
drinking water
and made a wide range of recommendations
in how we should be moving forward in
that space
in terms of moving forward with that
agenda the central government
has initiated three main reform
actions one of those being the
establishment of tomato arawai the new
drinking water regulator
one being a new water services bill
which sets out the powers of tomato roi
and the standards with which drinking
water providers
must meet and thirdly a range of service
delivery reforms
and those service delivery reforms are
centered on the creation of
four large public owned water entities
just take responsibility
for the management of drinking water
wastewater and stormwater across the
country
now as part of the recent local
government's government conference
the minister or the prime minister
announced a
two and a half billion dollar package
for councils as part of the water reform
process to ensure that
no council was disadvantaged uh
should they elect to opt into
transferring their three water
three waters assets to these new
entities
icc will in the coming months need to
make a decision on whether to opt into
these reforms
and pass responsibility for our three
waters assets and services
across to the new entity or whether or
not to
opt out of those reforms in determining
the structure number and scope of these
new entities government's been working
with
the water industry commission for
scotland to learn from their experiences
in water reform
they also entered into a memorandum of
understanding with local authorities
last year
where we've also provided extensive
information through a request for
information process
which has informed modelling undertaken
by central government to inform the
creation of the new entities
in july central government released a
report and its own modeling
around the the best options to move
forward in terms of number of entities
scope of entities um and
council is current council officers are
currently working through that modeling
information
to see how it compares to our
understanding of the data
and also to the work that was
commissioned by
morrison lowe on behalf of otago
southland which has also been happening
at the same time as the modeling work
undertaken by central government
there are some some quite key
differences between
the modeling undertaken by central
government and the modeling
work that's been being undertaken by
otago southland
and we are working well michael day as
our head of our finance team is working
through how we compare that modeling and
what assumptions have
have been underpinning the results put
out by
the department of internal affairs as
the representative for central
government
on that now over the next eight
weeks councils have been advised that
this is a period of engagement for us to
consider what questions we need to ask
have
dialogue with central government to make
sure that we are able to
close out all of the gaps of information
that we may have
ahead of the next period of
engagement and decision making that will
happen ahead of
us making that key decision on whether
to opt in or out of water reform
so the purpose of this verbal report was
to initiate discussion
amongst elected members around what
information you might like
or what informational question you might
like us to go back
to central government with um to ensure
that we have a full
and complete understanding of the
picture
working through the water reform process
thank you erin right so
what we have now is an opportunity to to
raise some
questions that uh councillors
i mean this is not the only time but but
it's a good start
nobody got a range i'd probably take all
that if i went through
all of them but i'll just go through the
main ones um
just just to be mindful of the um
money that was offered by the prime
minister of the 2.5 billion dollars
was actually only one billion of central
government funding
the other 1.5 billion which is 60 of it
is actually funded by the new water
authority so we've got to be careful
that we don't get lost in this equation
we're actually funding our own
investment
so the money 60 percent of them of the
23 million dollars that's earmarked for
this council
is actually coming from our own
householders our own ratepayers
it's not coming from central government
um
i find it really interesting that the
government's now and with
lgnz support is now backing us off from
declaring whether we want to opt in and
opt out it wasn't too long ago that they
said to us we had a hundred days to
decide on this
we're now down to i think about six
weeks where we need to
um give some sort of indication of the
questions that we want answered
and i find that a little bit frustrating
because we've had a lot of information
from the dia in fact we've been
overwhelmed by the amount of
information we've been given around this
issue and i think
government's now strategically moving us
to
not have a whole lot of councils like
the declarations that have already been
made by waimakariri
and by um honorary who said that they're
opting out
and so they're limiting their damage now
and just saying look just tell us the
questions you need answered and we'll
get these questions back here well that
that works on a premises that whatever
they give us back will convince us to
stay in
it was interesting when we had the um
independent advice from morrison low
which was an otago southland
um look at the situation and when we had
that here within the cargo they clearly
said to us and i'll
quote what the gentleman said he said
invercargill city council could well
make
a good case for opting out and i thought
that was really interesting
um because one of the issues about us
all being in the same walker as it were
is that there will be some degree of
cross subsidy which means that
those councils who have more affordable
networks who have done well on
investment
or have borrowing capacity
will will subsidize those that haven't
got that
so the argument that the government has
come to us on has said
um look those those councils that are
getting close to their ceiling and can't
borrow anymore
if we take the debt away from you you'll
have more capacity to borrow well that's
a fallacy an absolute fallacy because
all that's saying is we'll take the debt
away your householders will still pay
for it through the new entity
and then as council we can go off and
spend more money
well people would argue rates already
high enough up so i guess
i think it would be important for us to
somewhere along the line the next five
six weeks to have had a workshop
or a couple of workshops where we we get
our position
um worked up about whether we want to uh
stay in or stay out and i'd be
interested to know at the early workshop
whether michael can give us some advice
around the dashboard report that we got
recently because that's quite critical
as well
so i'll just leave it at that okay
thanks nobody um
anyone else look i've got a couple of
questions um first one's around actually
the decision-making process that we will
go through
currently the way it's and this is a
question to to ask
the dia currently we have a significant
engagement policy in fact every council
in new zealand does
and within that we list our strategic
assets
and under listed unders like the crown
jewels we've got tucked away
and that are our three waters horizontal
infrastructure
now for us to make any decision
concerning
a change of service of those we have to
go through what's called a special
consultation procedure and that means we
cannot do anything without going out to
the public
and doing a lengthy consultation about
anything
we we want to do with them so at the
moment the way the
local government act sits in that
statutory law
we can't make a decision we can't so
they're going to are they going to
one question is are they going to change
the act
that enables us to basically change the
robot
so that's one question the next question
is around privatization
now if if everybody hands over or
the government decide that maybe
legislation's a better way of
acquiring these assets um
privatization looms as as a real
threat when i was in the local
government conference a couple of weeks
ago
the prime minister mentioned that
private
privatisation of these assets wouldn't
happen
under her watch now when someone says it
won't happen under your watch you think
well
maybe there's a chance under a
government in a few years
later 20 years time that privatization
is actually an option because any new
government can
rewrite the books so that's another
question is about privatisation
because at the moment i see the way we
do our services is cost
council doesn't add on a profit we
deliver the service
at what it costs and that's what the
rate payers pay
if it becomes a private service
delivered
then are they going to do it at cost i
don't think so
so again that's one of my major concerns
as well
so anyone anyone else got any sort of
concerns about
the way this may roll out
um i'm gonna go um council
and then council cracker you just
obviously
for me i've missed a lot of some of the
discussions about this because i've
been early to council but um
my concerns are twofold if we keep
providing
water within invercargill
whether in the future we will plan to
charge for that and
what we can expect those charges to be
over time because i know that's been one
of the considerations that the water
will become overly expensive
and also to the advantages from three
waters for the security of our water
supply as far as
whether we would be getting better water
because of that as far as
all those things that um because i don't
really know much about our water supply
here whether it's um
got nitrates or what's what's in that
but whether we would be guaranteed
a better supply of water whether it have
any control about that but that would be
my
things that i'd like information on okay
um alex and then norway
um thank you um councillor pottinger
um i'm much of the same train of thought
as yourself and nobby that this entire
process i'm
sort of like they're quite uncomfortable
with in the sense that
i mean i don't disagree with the
government the principles of the
government are clear
you should be able to access or have
access to clean drinking water no matter
where you go throughout the country like
i don't dispute that
but it's the way in which this is being
almost
imposed on us that i'm uncomfortable
with all the reporting that we've had
like the morrison low report that
council clark referenced earlier and the
reporting that's come through
um nationally says that the economy of
scale of this is only achieved
and the efficiency with everybody opting
in and with
other councils um talking about opting
out like i don't see
how that is going to achieve what
they've set out to do
and in that case does that mean we'll be
forced in will this end up being
mandated is it something that rather
than
us actually talking to our community
about whether or not it's best for us
will we be forced forced into it i mean
they're already saying that they're
gonna well we already know
they're going to have to change the um
the local government act for us to even
make this decision because legally we
can't
we legally are bound to make the best
best
financially prudent decision for our
constituents like our local
rohi and they're asking us to make a
decision of national significance
um and the two just this two just don't
align
so i mean i don't agree i agree like
i've said
that the principles are clear everybody
should have access to fantastic drinking
water no matter where you go
throughout the country but it's the
process in which they're
they're undertaking it and forcing it on
us that i'm
really uncomfortable with so so just um
would you ask a question then would this
go ahead
with summon and some out yeah my
question is do you think it will be
mandated and will you and will it go
ahead with someone somehow
okay i'm going to go nobby then too
so just as a reflection to some of my
colleagues questions and i'll just
quickly run through them um the
privatization issue is interesting
the government has said or dia said on
behalf of the government
the ministers also said it that she
believes that the water entities will
have
fifty percent stakeholding by uh
by manafenoua so in our case that's
knight and that will safeguard
um any privatisation because the
legislation will require a 75
vote what she didn't say was
that he purapua has a has a potential
for future councils to be split down the
middle between
members at large and members from mata
fenwa
so if naitahu in the south island has
50 of the stakeholding and the entity
which is
the stakeholder groups that sit above it
and
half the councillors where malafenoa as
well that would be 75
so does that create a greater degree of
safety
alternatively does it open the door that
the entity could be privatized
in favor of
and when i've asked that question i get
a absolute brick wall that tells me
nothing
um it was interesting that marcus raised
issue
about water quality and water supply so
there are two different things water
quality
will be regulated under the water
services bill not there yet
and what it says is that there will be
what they call to refer to as a series
of barriers that stop
the infiltration of drinking water being
contaminated
those barriers are not necessarily
physical barriers they could be chemical
barriers as well
that'll be no different whether we're in
or out of the scene we will have to
comply with that regulation
on the issue of the supply we're one of
the few councils that has
a sole supply out of the river and so
we've got a risk there
and but our council to its credit has
identified this several years ago and
we're currently doing
testing of bores that will go into aquif
to find out whether we have a suitable
alternative supply because you do need a
backup
so that works well underway anyway it
was interesting that the minister
when asking for our questions back which
is what aaron's trying to collate now
um has said and said in writing
that she has yet to decide on the um
pathway forward and i think that's
government speak for
she has yet to decide whether they will
mandate or regulate us in
and and and the information we're
getting from dia
and from local government new zealand is
quite clear
unless we're all in um the minister will
have one or two options that would be to
back away from this process
and just regulate leave the councils to
do their own thing or she will mandate
us all
in and so i think we fight we face that
anyway
the other thing is the issue of economy
scale that if you're in and with a whole
lot of other councils
you can um you can get economy of scale
and and that's um quite questionable in
the south island
we don't have a a big um network to be
into even though geographically we do
have but
we don't have the number of connections
where auckland's got 1.7 million in
their region
and it was interesting that the the dia
has sponsored quite a few reports so
they've got the wix report out of
scotland
which talks about scotland and it talks
about tasmania but it does not talk
about
victoria which has also gone down the
same path
they've got deloitte's which is um a
report that's positive about where we're
going
but they haven't promoted the other
report which is the ferry aware report
which is quite a short report and well
worth reading because the summary quite
clearly says
the economy of scale cannot be justified
under this framework
and so that's only one of four
underlying planks to make this a
decision that we opt in and
opt out economy of scale can they
recruit and retain enough staff quality
staff
so that's the water engineers i guess
can the
industry deliver and clearly they can't
at this stage
and there is the issue of cross subsidy
and if you can take away a couple of
those planks
then the system starts to fall over a
little bit and that's something we'll
have to come to
can i can i ask what the questions were
in there since that's what we're trying
to collect
at the moment
nobody do you want to know there's a
question i think or you've raised a few
issues
um aaron you've got those here um
councillor abbott yeah well i'm a wee
bit off-wing on this one but
uh i'm concerned about the advertising
campaign on
television quite concerned about that
it's not
the perception to the public is it's not
a matter of if it's a matter of when
and i sort of indicate the big green
frog that sits on the lily pad and
smacks his lips after eating the
dragonfly
i'd like to see that question asked
because it determines to the public
that the matter is going ahead no matter
what
it's interesting you raised that
question then dunedin about
four weeks ago it was raised in front
of the uh the minister
about the advertising and uh she
apologized for the advertising
okay how it was sort of in a negative
way
towards councils but we still see the
ads are running
absolutely yeah yeah they might have
changed a couple of things
yeah yeah frogs still let's addre
i think the ones we're seeing are the um
the amended ads so yeah
so it has been amended um rebecca
my question is around um the fact that
invercargill
has it's already been mentioned that
we're in quite a good position
in terms of the infrastructure and all
that stuff to do with three waters
so my question would be if we opt into
this
entity will we gain any benefits or
discounts or
something uh because we are already in a
relatively good position and that
money doesn't need to be spent here in
the same way it might need to be spent
in other areas
and
those questions have been asked before
and we've had the dia response to those
right so the other the other the other
question i like to raise and i think
um council crack it might have got it at
the
local government conference and the
young persons
meeting with the minister about water
metering young elected members
yeah would would that be a compulsory
thing to make the system work
would we end up with water meters even
though
we've found it not necessary under the
current service that we do
for this whole system to work
you right
council clark two last questions for
leslie's benefit
um i'd like to know from dia um why they
haven't factored in the cost
of purchasing and implementing water
meters
on on the south i'm taking so you know
because we're going to need them and
then and and the second issue is
um there is acknowledgement from the dia
that all
water treatment discharges in the future
need to be land to land
it can't go out to water or which is
river or ocean
and i and i want to know why they
haven't factored that in as well because
89 of the treatment plants in the
country
go to water and that's a cost that
should be affected and so we know what
we're dealing with
okay that's excellent okay further
questions so thank you very much aaron
for that
and uh wins wins the next
step for us so
following we're in a bit of a holding
pattern following the
feedback of of our questions and
essentially working with central
government
um on our information gaps there will
then be
um a i guess a announcement
around what will happen in terms of next
steps and
engagement from there we have always
been working towards
the timeline of september this year
um the most recent correspondence though
i think probably suggests that there may
be a little bit more time
taken as part of this but we'll wait to
find out at the end of the eight weeks
the other question was with figures now
the dashboard figures
and everything are we going to get a
revision of our ones
uh considering the the deep positions
and stuff
is that going to happen uh are you
asking whether we will get a revision of
whether whether dia will revise their
figures
correct yes um i don't expect that they
will
i think the view is is that um
look there may be some assumptions from
from their view i think they think that
there may be some assumptions that
aren't quite right
but the bones of it is there as far as
they're concerned that makes a
sufficient
case to be moving on with okay
right thank you
we'll move on to
item seven which is the drinking water
compliance and drinking water standards
of new zealand
erin i'm actually going to ask
adrian cocker mr chair to come step
forward and just to take
any questions on this report um
i think generally we can take it as read
um would be just if any uh elected
members have got any specific questions
thanks adrian right councillor abbott
yeah just one little point um that i
think would be better for clarification
in the third paragraph
that starts that it is important to note
that the leniency has been applied by
public health
and it comes to sufficient evidence that
although monitoring was
absent i'd like to put the that although
data monitoring was empty
because you had the physical monitoring
but you didn't have the data
adrian you wanna uh yeah that would be a
a worthwhile edit i believe i'd like to
see that yeah
thanks for that any other questions
gradient not really a question but just
that the
the leniency applied by public health
south like that will become
in the next that tranche as the
water services bill comes to light and
comes to
its um standing that they will be the
new regulator that we will be reporting
to
rather than public health itself
right uh yeah i believe that would be
the case um
we're expecting that tomorrow roi will
actually have
legislative powers at the earliest
november
depending on whether the water service
is built goes through its final reading
which
i think is somewhere down the track
at the end of the day uh we don't even
know if there will be an annual
compliance
component until tomorrow roi
to give us a bit more information
there will be still compliance periods
and those compliance periods
are changing but the annual
compliance period was more for the
director general of health
as he was required under the public
health act
revised to have all
water authorities report yearly and have
a summary as to how people were going
thank you council lewis that's a very
basic question
the the reason for blowing the fuse was
just that one of those things there
wasn't an overload somewhere that needs
to be monitored
it was an overload by an electrician
doing something that he didn't know he
was doing
so it was the operator era i think
they were ironically putting in
extra monitoring to make the system a
bit more robust
and when that extra monitoring went in
they managed to uh a shorter circuit
which blew a fuse in the
ups which is the uninterruptible power
supply which
runs the monitoring is rather rather
reassuring
that there's a different reason for uh
yeah thanks very much yeah
we have been able to track down who it
was
thanks okay
question from his worship and then nobby
i'm just wondering mr chair if we've got
a plan b
if we end up facing the same situation
that we did in
1989 and got despite all the evidence
uh we weren't able to impose our will
and would we be in the same position and
if we are have we've got a plan b
so what happened in 1989
the local government was forced to
amalgamate okay and that's got to do
with frank's home
well same sort of scenario sorry your
worship but there were some
who didn't want to amalgamate and in the
end they were meant to talk to and that
blew a fuse
[Laughter]
worked all right for us because we front
footed it right okay
right thank you for that answer
counselor
oh sorry councillor clark yeah angry and
just as a follow-on from
alex's uh questions um it would seem to
me that the water entity doesn't take
over
2024 so in the interim will continue the
next two or three years to report to
the ministry of health no my
understanding is
that when tomorrow roi get the
legislative powers that it will be
switched over
and in fact the data national database
that holds all the water information
uh which is drinking water online uh
goes
offline as soon as tomorrow roi take
over
so we will be reporting to different
people i expect by
certainly by this time next year
when i asked a question from public
health south
about reporting into the future they
said well
until everything stays the same whether
the legislative
power or the regulator until such a
stages
tomorrow do i come on board which as i
say
will be when they get legislative powers
and so that's only an annual report
isn't it uh that's an annual report so
it's just a summary of
the state of the nations how we're
saying thank you
okay so councillor abbott you've moved
that we received the report compliance
and
drink uh compliance with drinking water
standards of new zealand can i have a
second please
all right so happy second day thank you
council lewis i'm going to put the
motion all those in favor
aye against that is carrick moves us on
to
item eight which is a report from
a report back actually from eil our
electricity and the cargo limited about
their network and its future capacity
with regards to electric vehicles
welcome andrew
cameron electrical engineer
extraordinaire
tesla driver the uh response for me i
always provided a high level at this
stage obviously
there is detailed questions required
they're
happy to have someone turn up and answer
those but it was thought
that at least initially there would be
the high level response regarding
their preparedness in terms of the
investigations they're undertaking and
and what they're looking at foreseen
needs to occur
and at this stage at a high level
they're satisfied that they're able to
meet the demand that they see coming
uh and also as they pointed out in their
response to the broader decarbonisation
issue
where you've got a transition from coal
burners to
electricity and those sort of other
activities going on in the same place
they're satisfied that the network can
handle those changes
but if you want some more detailed
responses happy to either put the
specific questions or have someone
attend but we thought it might be more
timely or better use of time to to have
the high level response first
no that's fine thanks for that so when
you talk about the the cold boiler thing
it's like identifying say a school or
something that
may be switching or or a business and
the forecast because and there's some
bigger industrial bodies obviously going
as well there's there's changes with the
milk
uh the way that's going and all the rest
of it um so there are big
transactions going on in that space okay
uh
questions for andrew councillor abbott
i think it would have been interesting
in my perspective anyway to know that
uh the 8 000 wattage per annum to twelve
thousand thirteen thousand be
interesting to know what that cost might
be
than power costs for the consumer
i think that i think that's actually a
typo there because it says
8 000 watts to 12 000 kilowatts
now that's not a 50 increase i think
there should be a kilowatt
on that 8 000 but
further questions we can come back with
that better yeah i mean it's just
happy to move the recommendations mr
chair secretary
i think your counselors have a counselor
ludlow
uh with that i'll put the motion all
those in favor
lies against has carried that moves us
on to the
activity report
and who would like to speak to this
um so i'm happy to speak to the
infrastructure portion but i might call
steve gibling out to find out if he's
got
any introductions he'd like to make to
the leisure and recreation
portion of the report which is up first
steve would you like to use the hand mic
or would you
welcome to the stand
right uh thank you mr chair
um only probably two comments one
is around the pool numbers we're still
seeing the tail of the covert impact
on the numbers but as noted in the
report the numbers
are catching up to pre-covered levels
which is good and i think that reflects
the consistency of
service and operating hours and
conditions um
in the parks and recreation section of
the report
we have noted that we've undertaken a
performance review
and of 182 parks
and we've noted in there that there are
six packs of poor
condition and that the other that's
going to focus our resource over the
coming months
as we look to understand exactly uh what
the remedial actions are in there
there's around 27 factors that we've
assessed across those 182 parks
for each park and they include factors
like play equipment
the network infrastructure which is our
drainage storm water
park infrastructure the horticultural
and immunity value
and also the turf and open space and so
we've now
probably first first time got a really
good sense of the standard of our parks
and that's going to drive our work
program going forward
um so happy to answer any questions okay
questions
counselor cricket thank you councillor
pottinger um i've got a question i think
um for steve um and your hydroside
report here we've got the old slide
average use for the total of 5800 usage
obviously with the old slide there
wasn't the additional admission charge
so um and i know that when we decided um
to go ahead with this hydro slide it was
fantastic because it was a good news
story for our community but it was also
going to be self-funding in the end
so i was just wondering what that 7 900
like if you could quantify that
financially possibly not today but like
so we could have an idea of where
we are tracking in terms of being
self-sufficient or self-sufficient
project sure um
i'll probably have to come back to you
with that um
yeah we do have a good sense of the
overall performance
um both in terms of numbers and finances
so i'll come back
at the next meeting thank you thanks
councillor arnold
uh mine was the same sort of question i
was just wondering about a performance
against budget
basically the same question yeah thank
you
nobby yeah steve just an issue that we
talked about earlier you and i talked
about which was the um
the issue of car parking around some
venues that are not club related but
they're more specific
than that so in particular around
turnbull thompson where there is a
significant lack of car parking for
junior soccer
and and around the stadium as well when
we have high profile
or high volume um events there that
there seems to be a lack of
a lack of car parking there so whether
there's something that
in the future you will look to to try
and address some issues here
yeah we are undertaking um an assessment
on the standard of our car parking
infrastructure on reserves
some of this will be as in the case with
surrey park we've included in the master
planning
but we are also looking at a range of
the other car parks that we've got that
we are maintaining at the moment
either directly or in partnership with
the clubs
some of these are tied up with leases
and so the team are currently just
going through and identifying the
responsibility
thank you thanks darren just heard of
that steve when you're talking to
football southland you might like to
raise the issue of the the way the
car parking up and around the turf
because they're driving right up to the
turf so they can stay in their suvs and
watch
which is causing quite quite a bit of
tune as they come off the roadway
there's quite a pool of mud there now
when there
are actually car parking spaces
available so
you know that's a frustration because
obviously it's up to council to
tidy up that mess
thank you uh steve i've just got one
question regarding
um the release of the new car compare i
was there that evening
yeah it was a great great uh
introduction for them
especially the wealth the welcoming from
michael skerritt
now to the two questions did that one
ever get out of his cage
yes that's good and obviously have they
have we had any feedback about how
they're sort of adapting
obviously this is a new pair brought
into an existing pair
for breeding purposes uh the initial
feedback was that they they were
acclimatizing
and but i can get some more detail as to
how they are currently i
i got feedback after the first couple of
weeks
and we were noticing a few behaviors
and so we've just now got to understand
a bit more so i can come back at the
next meeting give you a bit more of an
update
no no thanks for the magnificent birds
um marcus yeah um through your chair
just uh i apologize this is a bit of a
speculator but i see that footpaths are
part of your watch
just the number of um abandoned bus
shelters
particularly street out the back of
farmers and stuff like that that appear
to no longer be on routes they look
terrible
is there a plan to get rid of those or
are they just going to i'll
get to no no i'll get aaron to speak to
that
yeah no no aaron will answer that no
that's that's quite okay that's just
moving back to
um the infrastructure portion um so
we do i'd need to have a look at exactly
which ones but i
definitely have recently raised the
issue around
um some not great looking bus shelters
around the place
um quite a few of them are not ours
and so we're just working through the
process of either getting those
um tidied up or getting those removed
thank you whose are they um a range of
stakeholders not anyone particular
okay further questions
the recommendation is that the committee
receives the
activity report i'll move that can i
have a second please
counselor clerk i'll put that all those
in favor
against that's carried that is the the
end of the
public session of this committee
so can i have someone move that we
please go into public excluded
and the reasons being to confirm the
minutes
of the two public excluded meetings and
the reason of the property sale
seconded thank you council sopa put the
emotionalist in favor
against it's carried and we
are off
maintenance